hallo mein name ist luca ländlich will
kommen heute zu einem neuen video und
seht schon im titel das video etwas mit
justin bieber zu tun weil ich war
gestern auf einem konzert von ihm und
wollte darüber quatschen ist es egal wer
jetzt sehen die leute die kommentare
schreiben
das video ist kacke weil justin bieber
drin vorkommt oder darüber video macht
oder so aber ich habe einfach bock
möchtest zu erzählen wie ich fand das
konzert von ihm in köln und deswegen
mache ich weil es mein kanal sorry
sollte nicht so böse kommen
ich vermag ich bin mit einer freundin zu
dem konzert gefahren und wir hatten
tickets in reihe eins block 204 also
quasi direkt unten bei justin dran und
wir standen irgendwie als wenn er die
bühne zur seite gekommen ist bei der
heiz fünf meter neben uns oder so ich
bin euch mal ganz kurzen video ein wo
der halt genau da stand wo ihr seht wie
nah an ihm dran war und ich muss
wirklich zugeben ich bin kein belieber
also ich bin jetzt keine ultra krasser
fan aber ich war jetzt auch noch nie so
ein krasser hater von ihm also natürlich
fand ich seine musik früher halt einfach
schlichtweg scheiße muss ich so sagen
weil er zu dieser baby oder sofern ich
jetzt nicht so coolen allerdings
respektiere ich den menschen
justin bieber einfach dafür was er
erreicht hat und ich meine ersten zwei
jahre älter als ich und hat so viel
fucking mehr erreicht in seinem leben
und ich bin einfach ab urteil respekt
vor ihm und feierte jetzt die musik auf
mega gern ja deswegen bin ich damit
freunde zu dem konzert gefahren und ich
will das konzert jetzt mit diesem video
auch gar nicht schlecht reden oder sorge
mich einfach so ein paar aspekte so ein
bisschen aufgeregt und die wolke mit
euch teilen außerdem mache ich das
ladekabel meines laptops in meiner
wohnung vergessen und musste dann erst
bei einem kollegen ladekabel abholen
damit ich mein laptop laden kann ich das
video hier schneidet deswegen tut mir
leid das ist wieder ein bisschen spät
kommt aber gut auf den karten stand
drauf irgendwie 17.30 sommer seien wegen
lanxess arena in köln allerdings waren
halt freunde von mir schon in berlin bei
dem justin bieber konzert und da war es
halt auch das ist um 17.30 definitiv
noch nicht irgendwie prix eck mäßig
irgendwas garten sondern es ging
wirklich erst 19 30 los mit dem rapper
dj treppe hip hop ding ihren das ganze
dann auf jeden fall so gezeigt dass wir
irgendwie so um kurz vor acht in der
arena waren sodass wir passen um 85 oder
auf unseren plätzen saß man justin kamen
halt auch zeitnah aber vor der arena ist
uns erst mal etwas aufgefallen da ist
gleich dass justin bieber konzert und
ihrem irgendwie leute vorgekämpft
da lagen überall flaschen iso matten
decken unter welche da haben wirklich
irgendwelche art kopf verlangt selbst
arena über nacht überhaupt das paar
takte konzert zu kommen
das konzert dann auf jeden fall gegen
die sucht bitte nach acht halb neun los
und justin ist wirklich aus dem glas
kubicki zum glas dinge aus dem boden
nach oben gefahren wenn dass sie die
bühne war es ja quasi von unter der
bühne so nach oben gefahren und einem
glaskäfig war dann hier oben allerdings
an die wände geschrieben ist da wieder
nach unten gefahren und es dann
wieder nach unten gefahren
gefühlt waren 99 des konzertes justin im
boden versenkt und dann wieder ihr oben
müssen dann wieder oben und dann an der
seite kann konzert richtig so gut
beurteilen es das erste richtige konzern
wo ich von meiner seite aus hingefahren
bin ich war mal bei einem sting konzert
mit meinem vater in münchen und das war
halt weg so vier stunden ist ding
wirklich richtig bock auf das konzert
gegeben werden wahrscheinlich wenigsten
von euch kennen das ist sonnen englische
rockmusiker der aber auch echt schöne
lieder macht ich will jetzt keine musik
einblenden weil ich dann die gema
wahrscheinlich anzeigt oder so aber das
kommt man nämlich überhaupt nicht
vergleichen das wie wir das bei justin
rübergekommen es war das wirklich so von
wegen ja auch er macht diese tour ist
seit monaten
es ist irgendwie in köln die stadt die
nicht das juckt ihn alles nicht er hat
kein mal gelacht oder im vergleich war
es bei sting damals in münchen so nette
richtig bock darauf hat seine ganzen
leute davor gestellt hat selber dann
noch gitarre gespielt und hat orientiert
ist eine frau oder auch die wieder
geholt hat die leute daran arm genommen
habe dem publikum interagiert und ding
ist sowas von fiel ja der hat der ist
einfach sympathisch rüber gekommen bei
dem konzert aber ich will achtet
überhaupt nicht helfen ich kann in der
komplett verstehen dass er da keine
riesen show abzieht ich meine für ihn
war das locker schon die 80 90 100 diese
station war die gleiche show abzieht und
dass man da hat sich die ganze zeit
grinsen vorne steht nachher doch fotos
mit den fans macht es irgendwo auf jeden
fall auch klar und das hat mich schon
irgendwie abgefuckt weil
er hat kein mal gelacht und sehr viel
display beckers man hat gemerkt das ist
wirklich nicht echt gesungen hat es kam
halt mir als äußeren betrachter sitzt
nicht unbedingt als justin bieber fan
belieber kam ihr freund sind der
überhaupt keinen bock drauf gehabt aber
ein paar sachen war noch nicht richtig
neues was ich einfach aller coolsten
beim kompletten konzert fand war es
schaffen sich einfach mit einer gitarre
auf eine couch gesetzt hat und einfach
so ein bisschen akustisch gespielt hat
oder als er sich am schlagzeug gesetzt
und das ein bisschen rum geträumt hat
dadurch auch ein paar ausschnitte
vorbereitet hier für euch aber wirklich
sinnbildlich für das komplette konzert
steht einfach dieses video
jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade schon gehört
ich habe am ende von internet gesagt was
warum schreibt ihr alle bei justin stand
einfach nur noch in die menge geguckt
hat überhaupt nicht gelacht oder
irgendwie ich weiß nicht ob der
irgendwas genommen hat oder so das weiß
man halt nicht aber es war für mich in
dem moment ein wenig so aus als wenn
dann einfach stehen wird und sich so
denken was mache ich hier gerade
eigentlich habe ich dann wirklich gerade
wirklich bock drauf und jeder kreis ihn
einfach nur an weil sie an justin bieber
sehen aber für mich als je eine person
die ich glaub ihr wisst was ich meine
die schau dir gemacht hat was super die
ganzen kurios waren super es war
erkennbar sachen man grenzt wenn ich wo
ich mir gedacht habe okay da wird jetzt
ein trampolin hochgefahren und jetzt
einfach trampolin gehüpft und im
hintergrund nicht sein soll
da dachte ich mir auch so warum guckst
du wer trampolinspringen aber es war
schon echt geil gemacht also die
komplette lichttechnik der sound war
super
ich mag ja auch sehr viele lieder von
ihm wie beispielsweise la france seiner
lieblingslieder dafür dass er echt noch
relativ jung ist aber schon so viel
touren in den beinen hat er jetzt schon
stark gemacht um die ganzen kurios so
hinzukriegen muss man auch erst mal
hinkriegen also es war supergeil aber
mir kommt kannst du vorher selber keinen
bock drauf gehabt und es hat mir so die
stimmung gegeben das ist irgendwie alles
nicht so cool ist weil ich meinen du
fährst und konzert um künstler zu sehen
und dieser künstler verkörpert die
stimmung dass er darauf gar keinen bock
hat dann hast du direkt auch nicht mehr
so richtig glauben aber nach einblendung
wo man die richtig keine gruppierung zu
dem lied schild war es glaube ich sieht
die die alle echt super erfolg haben da
sind so kleine kinder auf die bühne
gelaufen und hat damit den getan ist und
so aber man sieht wirklich weil sich
beim run gesund habe dass er gar nicht
singen sondern sich einfach nur darauf
konzentriert irgendwie die kurve zu
kriegen aber dabei auch nicht fröhlich
gelaunt sondern wie ich einfach nur
seinen job macht wie eine maschine
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wieso ich
noch über ein video machen aber ich habe
wirklich viel geld für die karten
bezahlt und zwar in erster reihe und
irgendwie war es halt schon etwa schon
auf der einen seite eine richtig geile
erfahrung justin bieber gesehen der
wahrscheinlich gerade so der wg style
star antenne turtles kurios waren super
lichttechnik was super sound war super
konzert war super alles aus zweibrücken
ich habe auch viele leute von euch
getroffen und viele bilder noch mit
leuten von euch gemacht das war alles
wirklich unsere cool aber ich fand ein
bisschen blöd dass er da echt sehr
lustlos war aber ich kann's halt
nachvollziehen also ich meine ja ich sag
das überhaupt nichts gegen
ja das war dann so das ende der show er
hat dann noch mal kurz seine crew darum
abend oder ist dann quasi von der bühne
gegangen hat sich daher auch nicht
trassen auch mit den leuten geredet er
zwischendurch mal bei instagram geredet
dass ihn das faktum dass eine eigene app
machen würde doch so glaube ich ich
meine ich kann eigentlich relativ gut
englisch aber ein bisschen ins mikro
getuschel und da konnte das glaube ich
keiner so richtig verstehen aber das war
dann auf den forschungen von dem konzert
und das war es auch schon hier von
meinem video meine damen und herren
sorry falls es jetzt nicht den geschmack
aller von euch getroffen hat aber ich
wollte wirklich einfach mal meine
gedanken loswerden zu dem konzert weil
ein paar sachen die ich unfall guten
papa nie richtig scheiße aber wir sind
hier weil zwei die eigentliche darauf
den könnt ihr einen kanal abonnieren wer
auf jeden fall unterschiedlich und hier
seht ihr im video eingeblendet was ich
dann weiß ich jetzt